okay so what do you think about this
there's my piece I don't think it's
about free speech I'm sorry to tell you
this bill and I'll tell you why
very simple these same student that
signed those petitions actually invited
you for a debate and they said they are
welcome so they can have a conversation
that can ask you a question if they
don't like your views on television they
can switch channel but the commencement
speech it's a platform actually that
doesn't give the opportunity for
questions that doesn't give an
opportunity for pushback or even for a
debate it's a monologue it's not a
dialogue these students same student
feel offended feel offended that you
your views of Islam the generalization
and they said it clearly in their
declaration they said the generalization
perpetuate bigotry this is what they
said look I am all for freedom for
speech
I love debates I hate monologues when
you invite somebody to a commencement
speech you said it it's about the
students and the New York Times in this
piece this morning said you can counter
a bad speech with a good speech except
they don't have that venue that that
have that opportunity that day of
graduation they can't opt out of that
and a lot of nice things about that
subject just said but does that mean we
never have speeches every speech has to
be to people but this is a commencement
speech this is a commencement address
Kemal please once you dental air
actually listen would you accept an
openly anti-semitic person but I give a
commencement speech I'm a Jewish student
I I wouldn't actually I actually would
not accept that as I just said even Reza
Aslan says I'm not a bigot so I rather
resent the idea that I'm comparable to
an anti-semite all I've ever done was
basically read facts what max did you
read it
we'll never invite them but
I'm sorry but bill I don't think we want
to read you are comparing jihadis
Salafist suni you don't know her
difference your compare your all Moslems
in your your power and area and I am
actually SecureAuth more secular Muslim
and when you talk about this in a
certain way I have to tell you and it's
can you be offensive sometimes can you
be some people feel but it's okay to be
offensive that's what free speech is all
about a free speech is only speech you
like it's not free speech for a debate
he can't know but I want a company in it
that debate if you want I'm happy to
have that debate wherever you want he
was invited to be a commencement speaker
and then he made a statement they can
heal didn't know what to say I can
understand you can you be gay in Gaza
yes you can really yes you can and live
absolutely okay you know what it's even
more offensive because you're serious
asking cuz I've heard you see gays in
Gaza really I traveled the Middle East
is there a gay bar in Gaza this is what
I do for a living you're comparing the
majority of Muslim states with Saudi
Arabia or what happened what should I
call that I can get him back here so we
can I think I think issues beyond Muslim
I think it's about I think it's about
whether someone can be invited to give a
speech and people will listen
maybe they'll agree with it maybe they
won't but we don't have a situation in
Berkeley where people can't give a
speech I mean that's the whole essence
of the American system is it's people
can give us it's not everybody has to
have a Muslim community in this country
you are treating them like a fifth
columnist and they are not I guess
you're not yeah I'm the guess what if
these people these people are the Muslim
community feel threatened and feel
offended and they're underrepresented in
the media and underrepresented in
political avenues you never invite them
here on these issues ever invite them
here you're here it's
issue what he need on these issues I
mean I'm the one who says I want to stop
talking about this I can't because
things happen in the news as I was
invited to talk about something else
it was August Reza's been hearing a lot
and I'm happy that he's been here and
I've been here and I'm so happy to be
invited here however if you want to have
a serious conversation about Islam and
I'm sorry to tell you this bill every
time I say something you don't like it's
not a serious conversation or I'm a
bigot I'm sorry
in your world whether I'd say exactly
what you want me to say or else I'm a
bigot doesn't work if you look if you're
you don't have to say what I want
because what I want is not a war in
Islam I want to win the war on terror
when you are repeating the same things
that actual al Qaeda said the same thing
you're actually doing the work for them
so here used to send bin Laden used to
say this is not the war on terror this
is a war on Islam
my father was Muslim he was Sophie you
don't even know the difference between
Sufi Sunni Shafi'i Shia somebody who
does hey well for you yar we are all I
know I know that in many places in the
world if you left your religion what
would happen guess what let me tell you
something it would be ok you can walk in
you could walk inside a door and Gaza
and say you know what I'm a presbyterian
today maybe not in Gaza to be honest but
you can do it in Jordan you can do it in
Lebanon the majority of you are blaming
the majority for the for the criminal
act of a minority unfortunately the
majority are disorganized and there's a
small minority that are well I have to
go I have to dinars I have to move on
um I'm happy that you move on but I'm
telling you there's some people that
move
if you would have said some of the
things that you would have said about
african-americans and about Jews you
would be fired but african-americans and
Jews don't belong to a religion that
wanted to kill wanted to kill Salman
Rushdie for writing a book if we want to
get back to the free speech issue so I'm
sorry that's called false equivalence
okay I have to move on I'm so sorry but
I'm on bail I'm sorry if you want to
explore this I'm happy to explore it
with you after and any Avenue okay but
however you have to understand that
you're representing the whole group as
one you're actually reviewing Islam like
jihadis the same way they blue is they
view Islam is really sway we disagree we
can agree to disagree we agree to
disagree -